in questo video scopriremo sul serio
dove si nasconde il big foot and options
ucrania grazie allora ci sono le solo
expedition e group e spedisce aveva
facciamo sole spedisce un proprio questa
ricerca ragazzina dobbiamo fare da soli
allora e siamo partiti da qua vi spiego
come funziona il gioco l'ho visto e l'ho
scaricato subito è tipo avervi crollate
tipo the rake ray che era quel gioco
dove tu stavi nella foresta a cercare il
rake che sarebbe questo questa creatura
bellissima e credo che sia un po la
stessa cosa praticamente il personaggio
è venuto qua in questa foresta col
camper arrivato qua col camper e
l'obiettivo è quello di trovare il
bigfoot trova e cattura al big foot
primo obiettivo metti il bigfoot nella
gabbia che il suo obiettivo trova i
turisti che sono stati rapiti si è
possibile perché ci sono stati dei
rapimenti
va bè ragazzi io non so se questa
creatura davvero esiste però andiamo a
vedere ma prima vi era per tutti e c'è
anche della del del salame cose staranno
e carne tirare il bigfoot cola carnevale
no secondo la birra lottino meglio la
metto lì dai ragazzi allora la ricerca
dei big foot sono fiduciosissimo la
pistola segnaletica che nel caso ci
troviamo in pericolo almeno sparo in
aria per tutto il video dove testare in
ascolto e dovete avvisarmi se sentite
dei rumori sospetti di sottofondo tipo
mia madre che mi chiama perché è pronto
in tavola
no mi distrarre esterni nomi distrarre
mike è che cos'era sto rumore
bruttissimo che ho sentito ho sentito un
verso veramente brutto forse potrebbe
esserci qualcosa sempre stato leggenda
non lo troveremo oggi lo troveremo
diventeremo ricchi né euro a persona per
vederlo e facciamo i big money and big
money food al dulaimi 34 rievocato eh
vabbé minchia perfetto ragazzi allora
l'obiettivo è quello di andare a
piazzare un paio di videocamere e ci
siamo da desolanti saremo attentissimi
perché tra poco calerà anche la notte
videocamera cartello perfetto che cosa
mi cioè quella roba lì c'é una casa
dietro alla palude no fermi dove l'arma
perché quell albero al contrario è una
madonna
ok presa la trappola per orsi perfetto
ok orca la eva incastrata negli alberi
ma perché c'era un alce maledizione c'è
già un già uno shut no berlusca no già
c'è tensione per l'amor di dio mi
consenta qua giaceva il ragazzo inerme
qua giaceva la ragazza che aveva le sue
cose
cos'è tampax medikit proto medikit
perfetto
ma che chi è ma che ok
l'ho trovato manca la ragazza adesso è
direi che ci siamo ragazzo l'ultima ma
seriamente ma che ma l'ammazzo l'ammazzo
9 liquori di qua
ma porca eva o ma perché ci sono dei
ragazzi cè un fiume che bomba non avevo
capito
vabbè abbiamo fatto veramente tutto il
giro mi manca una videocamera ben
posizionata in questo punto se riuscisse
magari ci sia metterla sulla pietra
sarebbe una bomba ma non me la fa
mettere porca eva porca vacca mi sono
fatto malissimo ed è a questo punto di
piazzarla al mese l'avevano al miur gaz
mare nelle orecchie se hai fatto si sia
fatto male su un gradino para quel lance
schifoso 2a direi di piazzarla qua
ok ragazzi in teoria ci siamo quindi
abbiamo tutte le videocamere piazzate
siamo nel mezzo della notte e frego di
riuscire a tornare al camper che sta lì
che anzi abbiamo ora gas ho messo una
vita a tornare qua perfetto dopo due ore
passate a posizionare videocamere siamo
tornati qua giù la porta
sì ma che tettuccio scrauso e questo
piove dentro ma dai storia
questa è la videocamera nel mezzo della
palude perfetto seconda videocamera
ha sentito anche lei per ragazzi [ __ ]
[ __ ] pezzo di merda vaffanc ma mai me
lo aspettavo
mai nella vita me l'aspettavo sta roba
[ __ ] c'è stato un ora a guardare
le videocamere poi occupava a sé ma non
è vero l'ho anche ferito un pochettino a
poco poco park si spara solo un
proiettile pensate a marco si sono
proiettili di localizzazione anche un
proietto non è un fucile è normale
questo
ok ragan datori da fermi prova andare a
vedere se riesco a trovare qualcosa
nella sua direzione provo è che con
secolare va là chi diavolo è sta roba
una canoa c'è una canoa nel fiume aiuto
ok forse sta roba non è stato il massimo
dello stealth però va bene tutto a posto
zia tutto a posto bene perche hanno mai
un tizio ciao
eccolo eccolo l'ho visto ho visto l'ho
visto lo vedo lo vedo ragazzi lo vedo
fermi l'altra è sempre nei pressi perché
c'è un po cos'è lo vedo nella mappa lo
vedere la mappa avevo visto prima
o che credo credo sia lui non so un
bollino rosso credo sia lui non so
cos'altro possa essere
ricaricare ma un horror verna ma giuro
la cava neanche un film the stars è
incredibile porca vacca ma immortale
madonna che mira che manco mio nonno o
rega lo bello pure perso erano approcci
data veramente cazzo doppio azzurro era
tra dovevo piazzare una trappola per
ossia terra e far sì che mi venisse
incontro mi che sarebbe stato fighissimo
peccato perso anche il tracking malizia
non lo becco più adesso sarebbe stata
una bomba se avessi messo una trappola
per orsi a terra era morto ragazzi era
morto col fucile normalmente non li devo
niente c'è veramente devo usare o la
trappola per orsi non lo so io vabbè
ragazzi questo era il primo episodio di
bigfoot interrompo qua perché c'è anche
la seconda parte non la farà uscire più
avanti però vi sia piace allora è fatto
molto ma molto meglio di quello direi
che sarebbe lo stesso gioco proprio in
iraq che questa alta creatura fantastica
meno pelosa ma molto bella spero vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi fare di sapere se
volete il seguito cose il sogno bisogna
momento è un bel like anche vari social
come io tale descrizione sono il dvd
scateni ci vediamo lo possiamo vita
della ragazza
[Musica]